[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres dessert und
zwar habe ich mir gedacht warum nicht
einfach mal zwei dinge verknüpfen
ihr kennt wahrscheinlich alle baku war
das ist eine orientalische spezialität
gibt es in der türkei gibt es aber auch
in griechenland gibt es in den
arabischen ländern
und dann gibt's noch der new york
cheesecake den findet ihr bereits auf
meinem kanal das makaber rezept auch das
basis rezept und heute mache ich einen
boxer cheesecake ich verwende jetzt
heute dafür fertige backwaren blätter
ihr könnt dabei auch in meinem video
nachschauen
da habe ich euch auch gezeigt wie man
die backwaters selber macht wer keine
backware blätter findet kann übrigens
auch viele blätter nehmen ihm wichtig
ist im prinzip nur dass man einfach
dünner teig blätter nimmt damit der
kuchen wirklich richtig schön knackig
und knusprig wird
ich zeige euch mal was ich noch
benötigen für die triste verwende ich
ein päckchen backpulver teig 50 gramm
butter und für die nuss mischung brauche
ich jeweils 50 gramm wahllose haselnüsse
mandeln pistazien 50 gramm braunem
zucker und etwas zimt
ich nehme es ihm einen flachen
tortenring der hardt siebeneinhalb
zentimeter an höhe
den habe ich jetzt hier schon bestrichen
mit der flüssigen butter dem ich kurz
erwärmt in der mikrowelle und zwar schön
den rand der form bestreichen
damit der jugo blätter gleich daran
haften die banken blätter und auch schön
den boden also die back folie damit ich
einfach das aroma der mutter habe jetzt
nehmt ihr die teig blätter und die sind
wirklich ganz ganz ganz dünn
ihr könnt sie auch gerne auseinander
reisen und dann formen wir hier einfach
schön eine kruste also der anfang
dadurch jetzt einfach so ein platten
bisher überstehen lassen im rand
festkleben dann und zweites nehmen und
einfach überlappend hierhin leben immer
mal wieder butter einstreichen
damit auch die anderen blätter schön
haften und so vor mich jetzt die torten
koste
[Musik]
und hier muss jetzt einfach die form so
auslegen dass gleich diese flüssige
cheesecake massa nicht ausläuft
also praktisch alles schön dicht
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt fast die komplette
packung aufgebraucht wenn ihr ein
bisschen was übrig habt einfach wird er
gut einpacken und luftdicht verschließen
damit sie nicht trocknen und ich habe
jetzt etwa acht bis zwölf schichten also
wirklich richtig schön dicht und jetzt
ja so sieht gut aus ich lasse auch oben
ein bisschen überstehen denn diese
flatternden teig blätter sag ich jetzt
mal die werden dann richtig schön
knusprig der boden bildet so erstmal
vorgebacken und ich kann ihnen der
zwischenzeit die nuss bildung
vorbereiten
[Musik]
die nüsse werde ich jetzt grob hacken
daher nehme ich darf jetzt auch das
messer
und ich habe jetzt eine ganz bunte
mischung aus diesen vier verschiedenen
sorten
ihr könnt natürlich auch wenn ihr wollt
nur mandl nehmen oder nur bis tat ziehen
nur haselnüsse ich finde die mischung
aber ganz gut weil es sehr romantisch
wird
[Applaus]
dann die nuss mischung in eine pfanne
geben am besten in der geschichte
da werden sie jetzt noch mal schön auf
dem herd gerüstet so kommen die aromen
nämlich noch besser zur geltung
dann kommen sie hier auf den herd und
werden bei mittlerer hitze gerüstet
zucker gebe ich dann gleich dazu und
wenn hier der rand schön golden ist
nehme ich als bug war sozusagen raus
damit der teig intraprend den ofen kann
ich jetzt auch runterschalten auf 130
und die nuss mischung die reste ich
jetzt so lange bis sie lecker duftet
aber aufpassen nicht verbrennen lassen
immer schöneren jetzt duftet lecker
jetzt kommt hier etwas zimt dazu und der
brauner zucker dann nehme ich jetzt den
braunen weil er einfach intensiver
schmeckt als der weiße ihr könnt auch
honig nehmen
aber dann ist da wirklich darauf achten
dass gibt honigsorten die haben einfach
einen ziemlichen eigengeschmack
da könnt ihr euch ja mal ein cooles
video anschauen als ich beim imker simon
war
da hat es nämlich erklärt
jetzt einfach ganz kurz mitrösten so
dass der zucker leicht karamellisiert
aber nicht verbrennt also man sieht ja
auch dass er dann hier schon flüssig
wird das heißt da jetzt einfach nicht so
lange rösten damit war keine
bitterstoffe bekommen dann ziehe ich dir
die karamellisierte müsse vom herd
herunter und auch wirklich frühzeitig
unterziehen denn die pfanne ist ja auch
noch heiß das heißt da kann jetzt der
zucker auch noch verbrennen
also daher nicht so lange
karamellisieren lassen das lasse ich
jetzt ganz kurz abkühlen und kann schon
mal die cheesecake wasser zubereiten
für die kiesfüllung verwende ich 500
gramm frischkäse im doppel ram stufe 100
gramm sahne joghurt 40 gramm stärke 40
gramm honig 100 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt vier eier und den saft
und die schale einer zitrone zuerst
nämlich jetzt den frischkäse den ferro
ich ganz kurz damit der klümpchen frei
wird da können wir im prinzip auch
direkt den joghurt mit dazu geben
der joghurt bringt so eine leichte säure
eine schöne frische mit rein
schmandt geht aber zum beispiel auch
oder crème fraiche kurz berühren
[Applaus]
jetzt gebe ich hier einfach noch die
restlichen zutaten mit rein also etwas
wandel extrakt stärke
[Musik]
die sorgt für die windows etwas honig
den zucker eier
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich nur ein kleines bisschen
zu drohen und abrieb da müsst ihr darauf
achten dass die zitronenschale
verzehrbar ist schon eine ganz kleine
prise wirklich die übrige schale die
reibe ich trotzdem immer ab die frist
dann nehme ich ihnen einen kleinen
gefäßen so habe ich immer zitronenschale
auf vorrat
ich lass dir also nicht kaputt gehen das
wäre echt viel zu schade und die
ausgepresste zitrone
wie lege ich dann immer als
spülmaschinen der eu noch in die
spülmaschine rhein alles schön
verwerteten jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen zitronensaft dazu jetzt schön
langsam rühren
ich möchte jetzt keine luft einschlagen
sondern die masse wirklich nur cremig
und filmchen frei verrühren
es gebe ich die nüsse erstmal auf den
teigboden
das ist jetzt so typisch dagmar akkurat
gemischte nüsse zucker und so etwa eine
handvoll buch verschütten eine handvoll
die gebe ich jetzt noch auch für die
deko die hier am boden die reichen da
kommt jetzt die cheesecake masse
vorsichtig drüber
[Musik]
ich versuche jetzt die nüsse damit
abzudecken perfekt schön langsam dann
vermischt sich nicht mit ganz vorsichtig
bis zum rand streichen
es kann auch sein dass die bagger
blätter mal reißen aber das ist gar
nicht schlimm
der nochmals klopfen damit die luft
entweicht und dann bei 130 grad in den
backofen so dass die masse schön langsam
stoppt das blech schiebe ich jetzt ganz
unten rein also in die unterste einschub
leiste damit der boden von unten nochmal
ein bisschen bräunt aber die oberfläche
relativ hell bleibt
[Musik]
dem kiesweg habe ich im backofen einfach
abkühlen lassen
der war auch richtig schön durch
gebacken das sieht man auch daran wenn
man dran wackelt dann ist es nicht mehr
flüssig sondern schon relativ fest im
ofen abkühlen lassen und dann in den
kühlschrank stellen jetzt kommt hier
noch die samische drauf für die creme
nämlich 200 gramm sahne 130 gramm
puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt und
seiner partei das nehme ich zuerst den
schmand der kommt hier in die schüssel
und werde gemeinsam mit der sahne
verrührt man das von sich aus nicht so
stichfest daher kann ich jetzt die sahne
direktor zu geben
vanille extrakt noch ein puderzucker und
ein bisschen verrühren und dann mit
seiner partei schlagen
die creme gebe ich jetzt hier oben drauf
ich meine ihr könnt den cheesecake auch
so lassen aber ich bin eine weise creme
als abschluss echt schön jetzt ganz
vorsichtig glatt streichen
[Musik]
und jetzt nämlich hier noch die nüsse
die zurückgelegt habe und die sträucher
jetzt hier noch an den rand und dann
kommt die torte nochmal in den
kühlschrank wird war ein bis zwei
stunden bis sie richtig schön durch
gehört und dann probieren
der kuchen ist schön kalt jetzt sehe ich
ihn samt der bug folie direkt auf meiner
platte und dann die wrackteile darunter
weg
[Musik]
vorsichtig lösen jetzt so ich mir
jemanden der diese torte probieren
[Musik]
ich habe einen auftrag gefunden okay das
sage ich vielleicht nicht wenn ich so
ein scharfes großes seine handabwehr mag
dass der markt er opfert sich immer zum
probieren ja also ich bin selbst
gespannt ich denke dass z berichtet so
ein bisschen
also wenn das nicht gut wird mit
pistazien oder er eigentlich seine
yamaha star crh sind dass mandeln so
alle nüsse die ich finden konnte im
schrank
ja es geht gar nicht so schwer wie ich
dachte
mit dem schneiden ich glaube auch mit
vanille was habe ich noch drin
ich glaube bisschen zitronen abrieb von
new york cheesecake gebündelt mit backen
was ich nur machen würde nächstes mal
den bug weiter unten in den ofen
schieben und nur unter hitze denn dann
wird er auch am rand und unten richtig
schön braun und bleibt nicht so hin
deswegen ist man könnte natürlich noch
zuckersirup dazu machen aber ich habe es
jetzt mal weggelassen
denn ich glaube dass die süße vom kuchen
schon heiß
die sonne ja ich liebe ja früher ging es
noch so aus der sprühflasche platz nicht
angesetzt es gut mit den listen ja ich
krieg auch vor der anstellung ist echt
schön schön oder sowie sahne oder
joghurt oder joghurt habe ich in der
cheesecake masse und oben sahne mit
schmand genau alles zusammen also in der
türkei ist es gar nicht unüblich dass
man desserts mit gabel und messer ist da
gibt es auch das eis man nach straße das
wird aus ziegenmilch hergestellt und das
einst ganz fest und da ist man noch mit
gabel und messer
gerne gibt immer so dass von mir auch
spaß an dem krad ein stück mit und dann
findet sie das rezept genau wie ihr alle
anderen auch auf handys - blog.de und
ich glaube das ist wirklich ein rezept
es sieht einfach besonders aus man kann
es wirklich zum ramadanfest machen oder
auch so mal zu einem geburtstag oder zur
nachfeier es ist einfach mal was
außergewöhnliches fehlt dir irgendwie
was frisches dabei früchte so gar nicht
perfekt also probiert gerne aus ich
wünsche euch noch einen richtig schönen
ramadan eine schöne ramadan feier vor
allem und ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr
das rezept nach macht danke bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]